oh yeah oh yeah we are back at the
constable arena here on the intro music
now take a dig ticka ticka ticka yeah
wow you can't scream and boy and you
look thank God it took guys will be
ready marker already and officer it was
like three seconds and it's got to be a
new record
God we are back new podcasts hair is
crushing it today it is well it was up
in that lake on top of my head ponytail
last night it looks good or like that
your hair is brought to you by
innovation and his podcast is brought to
you by Squarespace sweary Squarespace
shirt perfect Squarespace calm for some
of the best websites you can make by
yourselves you don't need anyone use
make it
it's very pretty very good looking
websites professional and they have 24/7
support yeah you can make yourself but
if you do need someone they have 24-hour
customer service like personal help help
I wish I had 24-hour personal hell I
want 24-hour help with everything
enter JJ at checkout and you get 10% off
your own website so check out
Squarespace calm thank you Squarespace
for sponsoring us always
alright um well first of all I want to
say that I hope you guys like the way we
look this week I've been going through
some I guess you could say trial runs
with this camera and certain color
profiles but I think I might have found
one that works so let me know um and
we've changed the look of the podcast a
lot what it is if you look on the
YouTube chances we like different
laptops like well we have phases like
right yeah but um I I particularly like
the phase where we were using that
little handheld camcorder and one of us
was always out of focus so like one of
us was like violently out of focus like
crazy and another person who couldn't me
like it was like they were blurred hey
man all that matters is that we're just
we're doing it ourselves doing like
something fun who cares is one of us
violently uncle that we've that we've
come pretty far from you from starting
the podcast that the best part about
that was that you just use your
imagination as to what the other person
looks like
like is Jenna with Julie in his podcast
or is she just with another guy because
oh well never are you listening to the
Sarah Palin Billy Ray Cyrus podcast yes
dying laughing we were so stupid
it is funny in hindsight yeah it's
pretty fun I can't believe we did I
can't believe we didn't either a whole
podcasting character like that or well
they did it but I mean ideally I think
we want to have a cooler background than
just [ __ ] styrofoam because or you
know soundproofing because it's just
kind of boring to look at but also maybe
like Don line will have some sort of
green screen with a graphic or something
I don't know someone was just in time
well we we've been taking like yeah yeah
one little baby step at a time first I
want to make us not look completely
busted why is there a fly in the podcast
room this place is supposed to be
quarantined hmm this is going to be
distracting he better [ __ ] settle I
don't know isn't that Dame's
that's that's not babes babes as video
games is kept mock does my makeup and
there's a fly in the room and Julian was
being mock and I was like oh there's a
fly and he's like yeah that's my Pat his
name is James James the fly I mean this
isn't babes babes names is way better
behaved mmm okay got it
gtfo you babes impersonator anyway today
we wanted to I thought it would be a fun
podcast topic to discuss and kind of
like I guess we reminisce or just look
back on some of the old jobs we've had I
know I'm not sure that we had done this
we haven't done a dedicated podcaster I
think we might have touched on it in
certain podcasts but we haven't had oh
my god that's gonna drive me nuts stop
looking at him stop looking at beams
it's not the babes impostor it's like
it's like an Elvis Presley in Vegas he's
one of those babies I'm just kill him by
the end of the podcast kill him that's
your objective if you want a podcast
alone I'll hunt him down it'll be like
that episode of Breaking Bad the whole
episode is dedicated to killing one fly
I mean you should probably get a weapon
ready
that's all you can do he came so close
to you my god he's like he's rubbing in
my face for that for those you guys
listening on Soundcloud 19 I'm sorry
there's a fly in our room and it's
really [ __ ] annoying yeah what if
this whole podcast is just us talking
about where it is in its current status
then you'd be really frustrated if
you're listening and not watching or
would it be like a riveting horror story
because you don't know what's happening
that or if I could be one of the other
if you hear a loud slam - it's probably
me knocking always right there oh all
right you know what you're talking about
jobs and [ __ ] I'll make her happy
Julian's read like he's not been able to
focus and you unplug our headphones oh
here we go man um yeah we should talk
about our old jobs but like starting in
order from earliest to most recent yeah
I like that and because I used to have
some funny stuff or some weird stuff
what was like oh my god really food oh
he's really he's got a magazine right
now why did you fold that it was keeping
that tool in there's coffee all over
okay you weren't keeping it yes I was it
was it's a magazine that Mikey pitch
sent me from Sirius XM and there's like
a tiny little picture of me in it so I
kept it cuz I keep that kind of thing
it's night it's exciting and this
[ __ ] using it to kill a fly
it's over here he's in front of the
lights he's over my head oh my god
Julian I swear oh okay no all right boys
over here oh okay this podcast has the
rest hey Julian you better get him I'm
trying he's so bad oh my god he just
like Michael Jordan jumped across the
room
a [ __ ] aw I didn't owe you Oh it's over
man is over my head
it's over my head I need a good angle of
room mmm so what was your first job okay
so here here's what's gonna happen I'm
going to tell you about some of my first
jobs and Julian is going to narrate his
flight activity in the background oh
he's on top
yeah yeah yeah good work doing it why
you bring him over here going ill put
him away [ __ ] is gone yeah I saw
all right you know all right get the
[ __ ] down we go into the movie thought
that she was gonna take an hour fly
there's a vine the guy's name is meet
John Mars I think they show Mars you
guys you're welcome pretty real are we
there yet you go sit the [ __ ] down we go
into the month you thought that she was
gonna take out that's such a good vine
that's like one of my top five favorite
by the gate anyways okay
so I think one of my first real jobs cuz
I was a babysitter and stuff yeah for a
while yeah one of my first real jobs
that I got I think I was 15 I got a job
at a day spa hmm yeah yeah yeah which is
like you know they do facials and
massages and waxing and I would go there
like a few days a week after school from
like 3 to 6 or something like that like
not it wasn't like a six hour shift or
it was an afternoon but to me it felt
like for-fucking-ever and I would also
get so ravenously hungry and they would
have like Hershey's Kisses and so I just
remember like trying to steal as many
pieces of candy as I could while I was
there so so hungry yeah but my job was
to like fold towels and like clean and
do all the laundry and uh clean up the
manicure and pedicure rooms and they
would do like medical pedicures so they
used like [ __ ] razors on people's
feet and stuff and like they got rid of
it and one of those like biohazard box
yeah we put needles yeah yeah yeah so we
I had to clean up all this like the most
discussed not just like a pedicure but
like the most disgusting pedicures and
manicures and toenails and one of my
least favorite places to clean was the
waxing room Wow so I would clean up like
what does not sound good
people's pubes and [ __ ] on them and how
old are you 15
appropriate but I got paid I think like
six dollars an hour which was above
minimum wage at the time what was
minimum wage it was like I can't
remember but maybe four seventy-five or
five dollars is in New York is New
Year's for six dollars was really
generous especially for a 15 year old
yeah and I saved like all that money it
was good it was fantastic I didn't spend
it saved it it was great
but he saved like all you saw like you
still have that and oh yes yes I have it
in box box I got paid in cash trillion I
kept my money in box you did know I had
this see-through wallet we'll get to
that
oh my god you see through wallet I'm
ready I'm ready to hear about it what
was your first job I'm like racking my
brain well I know one of my first like
legit on the books Jobs was a little
league umpire I did a lot of jobs like
babysitting where I wasn't necessarily
like getting a paycheck and clocking in
and out it was more of just like you
know I can babysit one of the jobs I did
when I was young is so my mom I talked
about on the podcast before but my mom
used to do a lot of like set art for TV
shows she's an artist and she would get
hired by certain shows and um you know
uh studios to do work and sometimes my
mom is a baller so she would like
negotiate with these people and be like
yeah like I'll do all that if you can
like drop it off in my house and then
pick it up when it's done my gods do it
at home like God because she like she
could she was good and I was for PETA
you know for them to just divide by
whatever she wanted so there was one um
I had said she worked on heroes and
there was this one episode of Heroes
where it was a high school sports scene
like probably a high school football
scene because of the cheerleader I think
and she had to make a bunch of like
student made signs that the students
were holding in the bleachers like go
team and [ __ ] and she basically brought
it home that time and she was like hey
Julia my my 50 bucks
like just draw like what you know all
these messages on these signs because it
was kind of appropriate I was like 13 I
was like almost the high school age it
looked like it could have been done by
me so we spent a couple hours just in my
mom's studio just painting
I [ __ ] up she's like oh it's okay it's
all good and she like she like made it
look right and then you know we
submitted she know submitted to the
people and paid me 50 bucks in cash and
then I remember we watched the episode
and we got to see some of them on TV
which is like the coolest thing ever but
that was like one of my first ways I
ever made money as a kid it wasn't a
legit job but it was was for my mom and
she included me so I was cool oh well I
mean if we're going that route I used to
do yard work for my neighbor we were
talking about this with Josh pay me in
silver dollars and [ __ ] yeah but I also
was like the go-to pet sitter in my
neighborhood yeah I never did that and
any time because we didn't have pets cuz
her mom's so allergic so anytime someone
went out of town I was like hey I'm
available you know you want me to come
pet your kitty yeah and I watched a dog
named Duke a bunch he's the best and I
watched a cat named Shackleton and
Shackleton
yeah Shackleton I think that's a dope
name like furry furry furry kitty and he
didn't even really like want to hang out
with me but they would pay me just to go
over and like chill at their house and
like clean the litter box so that the
cat like had a person there and they
would leave like frozen pizzas in the
fridge yeah and like that was great they
live right next door to me and one time
it was like for you know a weekend or
something and they paid me $60 and I
came home and I told my mom I'm like mom
they gave me $60 she was like that's
great I am like no that's like it's like
life to catch like triple what I should
or not yeah and I like marched back over
there and I was like I think you made a
mistake and I handed them like $20 back
and they're like really I'm like yeah I
can't this is too much money I don't
know what to do with this and they were
like well okay like all the college kids
that we pay have no problem taking 60
bucks but I remember being like yeah but
I didn't do anything
you're like no other kid ever I didn't
know what to do I see darkness good on
you kid though no I was found so well
especially the well the guy who used to
live in there would pay me a silver
dollar anytime so big it's like an
overwhelming I don't know what to do
with that money no for sure I wasn't
gonna spend it but ladies me I think you
pay me a little too much I don't know
the over
have in it yeah now just pet your cat
it's not even worth that but $60 to pet
your cat was luck man I get that job as
an adult what was it a 2-way petting zoo
did the pit pat you back no he never put
me back oh my god his brother's here oh
did he live oh my god Jillian there's no
[ __ ] way he survived that you guys
saw him he was dead he's a zombie fly
fly he's back alive
he's not a fly he's noticeably slower oh
my god Jillian it's in front of the
lights in front of the light oh my god
you know any regular people would stop
this podcast and start it over Julian
but we're just gonna let him oh did you
kill it I well I thought it'd kill her
the first time but the bodies are weak I
want to make sure he's yeah but where's
his spirit
you should let his spirit live Jillian I
cannot believe he oh here he is
no oh I don't like when he does that
when Julian kills a bug he doesn't just
like hit it and then like take it
outside or something he takes his foot
and then like can I tell you what I do
that wishes it across the room can I
tell you why we're living it that's why
I hit him with a thing I thought I was
being nice and he came back from the
dead you got a smudge him into the
ground so he doesn't have two lives I
know but there's like spiders and stuff
that you kill on the wall and squish it
on the wall and there's still like bug
parts on part of you we clean it's okay
so my job okay yeah I'm sorry about that
guys I'm a hundred percent sure that
that flag is turned into a zombie he did
though he did you guys you I gave him a
close look at the fly like that was a
[ __ ] dead ass fire and he legit is
now dead I'm not coming back for if he
comes back at like I don't know
I'm not going to kill him gonna freak
out yeah so I did a lot of jobs
sorry good and you done okay I did a lot
of jobs surrounding like Little League
when I was a kid because that was like
my life everyone just was always at the
park playing Little League or watching
other games playing really watching
other games or working the snack bar you
did that a lot which is fun because you
just snacked on [ __ ] the whole time but
there was this one job that I basically
like created for myself which is really
cool I was like in high school so this
is why after lily but I was in high
school and I was like in love with
catching that was my position I like
found catching the be so fun yes hammies
and quads don't lie though Gillian oh
thank you baby
he's got like a jacked lower body even
everybody's [ __ ] even more [ __ ] is not
what I'm saying
even todrick Hall can we tell the
todrick sorry you can tell the todrick
sorry so before taught todrick Hall is
like really big on YouTube he's really
big on everything for those of you don't
know if you ever flown Virgin Atlantic
there's a music video and he's named me
he made is hey it's pretty dope video
Dan and man that's todrick but he like
Cory I don't know for that particular
but I imagine he choreographed and wrote
the whole song like he's just wonderful
and he before he knew that Julian and I
were dating he had seen Julian like an
event Maria Oh Miranda show and I wasn't
there I forget what I was doing that
night but I couldn't go I was out of
town I don't know I can't remember I
can't membrane either um but todrick had
seen and met drill Ian and sneakily took
a picture of your butt because he was
like it's like the best spot ever and
then you know months later he realized
that Julian was my boyfriend and todrick
texted me he was like can I tell you
something without you getting like
creeped out and like yeah sure he's like
here's like I don't think he sent me the
picture but he was like your boyfriend
literally has the best but I've ever
seen like I wanted to take a picture of
it did take a picture of it and I like
died [ __ ] laughing like dude I know
and then I took a picture of your butt
and sent it to todrick
I love todrick he's very nice but that's
a hilarious story until I clear yes
right I mean I love that you just like
Jenna came to me and she was dying
laughing like crying laughing to the
point where she like couldn't even speak
I was like what is going on cat who you
texted did she was texting him like like
non-stop and I was like what is going on
she was like yeah so remember that guy
todrick you met at the show a couple
weeks ago and I was like yeah yeah I
remember him
because I met him like we shook hands he
introduced ourselves he like sat next to
me and she was like yeah he took a
picture but cuz he thought it was a
really great butt and now he sent it to
me because he now find not found out
that we're dating
Isis Lee really funny so crying laughing
I just love that he took a picture of it
like he didn't just like he wanted it he
just wanted to see it like he wanted to
remember was really genes you can even
see my butt that's what you think um but
anyways anyway better to learn it back
to little way those of you that are
wondering just how Julian's lower-body
game strong is strong your body is
strong your butt game is strong yeah I
mean I it was the catching and then I
also went through like kind of a
deadlifting phase in my life where all I
did was that okay so I played catcher
and I loved catcher like I love catching
to the point where I did like there was
a point in my baseball career where I
didn't really care to hit I just wanted
to play catcher I enjoyed it so much
like working on blocks working on my
footwork working on my speed everything
it was just so fun and interesting to me
so I had kids like who were you know
playing literally with my younger
stepbrother and [ __ ] like that come to
me with their parents say would you give
you know my son catching lessons and I
had taken catching lessons when I was
like just entering high school from a
guy named Brent main he was a pro
catcher for the Royals and a couple
other teams my dad yeah my dad hooked
that up I was so so thankful for that I
mean that was the craziest experience
ever but basically I had those like
couple of lessons my dad like you know
paid for and it was expensive but I
started to give lessons to kids like I
would they would come over and we had a
little grass area and I would work
drills with them and they would pay me
well
and I like enjoyed every second of it
you know because that that kind of thing
when you are like you're you're treated
like you're a professional at something
even though you're not like you just
know sort of what's going on you help
the kids and there was this one kid I
helped for a while and he was like
really struggling like he wasn't getting
a playing time and I worked with him and
I worked with him and then he just
started to like kill it and it was so
cool oh yeah he hit a home run I
remember and Little League and I was
like dang like that's awesome so that
was like I would say probably my
favorite jobs as a kid it's pretty cool
job that's really cool job huh I don't
think I ever had a job in softball like
I was always playing and then I was done
yeah like I definitely helped kids like
we did a bunch of clinics and stuff but
I was never getting paid or we would do
it we we would do it more in the way of
like well cuz when I was a kid we would
go to like colleges and stuff for summer
camp for softball yeah yeah and it was
like the coolest thing in the world when
you're like a you know teenage or young
teenager 12 13 and college girls are
teaching you how to play oh my god that
camp was like my favorite thing in the
entire world and I really wanted to go
play there when I got college Dage or
whatever but then I was like no I don't
that's kind of in the middle of nowhere
like not really what I want my life but
I would have loved to do it but um then
when we were at Suffolk what we would do
is we would sell tickets basically to
like a Suffolk clinic and kids would
come and we would teach them you know
anything
what's better if we do it as a team but
we'd use it to fundraise for uniforms
and cleats and bats and all that [ __ ]
yeah so today's never me personally no
that's really cool although I've been
tempted plenty of times I've been up
because I feel like it's more okay so no
one has ever reached out to me I'm
relatively under-qualified at this point
to teach pitching lessons but when I was
like you know my [ __ ] prime noon or
like any kind of softball lessons I
would see girls playing softball
remember in Boston where I showed you I
used to live that Park
yeah there'd be like girls and stuff out
there like man could really [ __ ] light
up that one I was right near your old go
light up that bitch's life right now if
I just give her some tips but I like how
it's something yeah would that be though
if you were like just a kid
you're gonna park playing softball and
some person came up to you and was like
hey you know what you gotta do
I'd like the [ __ ] out of here well
creepy creep that just depends I'm
watching me through your window ah
that means depends then you can be you
can take it the wrong way but you can
also be like wow that person is talking
about oh yeah my dad though he on his
Street there was a older man that had
played in some ridiculous level of I
didn't know was a thing fastpitch like
adult yeah yeah yeah but he could throw
like I so underhand if you pitch like in
the 60s that's nice is [ __ ] great
it's like gross
he would pitch mid 70s and I can't
remember honestly what his name was or
like some [ __ ] record that he held oh
he came over he was like 70 at the time
my girl came over it was playing catch
with us oh yeah times and me and my dad
were bulges like [ __ ] [ __ ] our
pants like it was bananas how fast and
how hard he could throw and he gave us
some tips but my dad for the most part
was the one that taught me because he
would just read books yeah and then I
didn't get a coach until more like you
know worked with anybody until I was in
middle school really neat well I like
how you have you know certain issues but
you you know you talk to other people
and they help you solve those issues
like you know say if you're in the
middle of the night trying to fix a
problem with your website and you talk
to someone rather Squarespace is there
for are you stag lasers that middle of
the night middle of the night they will
be there for you to help with the issues
that you're having some where are the
issues that you have when you don't know
how to pitch that's right or catch or
catch blah anything the issue is odd so
if you wake up at 3 a.m. and you're
unhappy with how you're Squarespace
website is going there will be someone
there waiting to help you make it better
Squarespace comm is by and far one of
the best ways to create a website for
you
sell for your business for blog whatever
you want an online store speaking of
which if you create a website it'll come
with an automatic online store for free
its included in the website amazing you
get to choose the template customize how
it looks
add pictures links your social title
everything so make it yours go to
squarespace.com and enter product code
JJ at checkout for 10% off of your
website cost which is a it's a nice
little it's a nice little chunk off of
what you'd be paying and Squarespace is
I would say pretty affordable for the
masses and that's what's great about it
they make it they democratize it make it
easy for anyone to have a good looking
looks fantastic and they're great
supporter of the podcast absolutely
thank Squarespace well I mean this is
but this is awesome cuz like all of our
jobs like surround I mean at least a lot
of them have surround the sports we
played so like my next i so i'd said i
umpired leg how is that it was uh it was
okay so i was like 12 this is before I
was you know you were pumping for like
little baby yeah so you're like how does
a twelve-year-old up like aren't twelve
girls playing no I was I was umping
something called five pitch and what
five pitches
it was between t-ball and Little League
wait so the coaches pitch and stuff oh I
pitched ah there was a machine set up on
the mound and I fed the balls through
the issue oh my god and you owe and I
owe this is the sweetest league so it
was called fire pit and I got hired as
an UMP and let me tell you I was like
this was like so much pressure because
the head of the UMP since like Santa
Marta was like you know he hired me and
he was a real deal he humped all my
games and I was like okay you're my boss
now like I'm kind of scared so I had the
duty of feeding the ball into the
machine so the kids could hit it
calling strikes or balls which I mean
how do you call a striker ball when the
kids two foot tall and the machine is
like a whole 50 feet away like
completely inaccurate anyway so I had to
call strikes the ball is safe and out
but at the same time I also felt like I
kind of had to help the kids like figure
it out
problems the biggest problems I ever had
were just parents who were like taken
away to crazy like there were certain
plays where you know I would the kid
would slide but then he would like run
around and like roll around and then he
would technically be safe but he like
went out of the baseline I didn't get
attacked
I'd be like you're out and the coach
would come running at me like I didn't
see attack and I'm like these kids are
[ __ ] six like they don't even know
how to play let it go anything but it
would happen way more often than you'd
expect and so I would say that was a
four 12 year old who's still like you
know I'm just a kid like having parents
like coming out thank you that was the
scariest but I think it also made me
develop a little like you know stand up
for myself a little bit because
sometimes I you know no dad I have the
power generation on the umpired [ __ ] out
yeah exactly Sarah yeah yeah and I
remember I would have like talks with my
mom and dad like you know like this is
intense I like it but it's intense and
they're just like yeah I gotta hold your
ground and then my parents would come
watch me on they would come to the games
that I was something and watch oh I had
a blue shirt with a patch and everything
and then you know I graduated in two I'm
paying little league when I got older so
like I was behind the plate for a couple
games which was really really fun you
know you're wearing the mask and I love
that because it was like catching sort
of you know you're back there but yeah
I'm firing this was a one of the main
jobs I had as a kid that's really
awesome
yeah yeah I've never been an umpire I
don't want that pressure on my life
thank you yeah I mean you learn really
fast that I always say this like I use
this as an example like an analogy for
other situations and life's but in life
but um an umpire is like when you like
when you're an umpire the most you can
please everyone is when you're
completely invisible so when you're
doing your job right nobody notices you
but when you make one small mistake
that's when people pay attention you
which is a very odd dynamic you know
coming from an athlete when you know
it's very different and so like you're
never going to please everyone you're
always going to piss someone off and if
you don't piss anyone off you will be
completely invisible
that's really great yeah I even got so
into it because I did it for like maybe
a year and a half that I went to a dozen
Eternity when you're 12 absolutely I
probably did for longer but I went to a
Dodger game and it was like I think it
was like with my little league team or
some of the Little League team and I got
to meet the pro umpire for that game
because he came over and I was what I
was like with my mom and he came over
and my mom like got his attention was
like hey my son's like a junior umpire
would you like to me and he like signed
something for me and now I'm on some
newsletter still I get emails from the
Association still saying like you know
here's our monthly news or whatever but
I was like stoked to meet a major league
umpire oh yeah I bet you made that guy's
day oh maybe I don't know yeah I feel
like he never gets that yeah nobody goes
up to an umpire's like hey y'all you're
really great their autograph exactly I
never thought about like that that's
interesting you probably made his day
felt so special thanks blue right blue
hmm do you have any more well I mean I
did it was a camp counselor for years
and that sort of thing but when I was
trying to think of things that I did
when I was younger like around that age
but I think when I was a little bit
younger than that and this wasn't really
a job so I wasn't getting paid but I was
an altar server for so long mm-hmm and I
used to do like at Julian your what hat
your mom's Jewish yes I'm just yeah but
like you didn't grow up going on thank
you I went sure it's couple times but
yeah I didn't did you go do guys not a
temple ever couple times for like
holidays like you know John Kippur right
now we would go as a couple of those kid
moves well my dad and my mom would take
us to different churches my mom would
take us like into the city and like they
had a [ __ ] choir like peace be with
you took like a half an hour it was we
call it like party church like it was
good [ __ ] awesome and then my dad
took us to like a much more traditional
church yeah and uh
I was an altar server at my dad's Church
and so like I would get my little like
schedule printout and uh I you know I
would do like a 7:00 a.m. mass and look
at 9:30 mass it was
busy and all expanded on Sunday and like
we had our robes and we had to wear like
tassels and we left them at the church
yeah but I remember the most shocking
thing to me so your duties include like
you know you sit through the whole mass
you like carry staffs and like you know
you wash the priests hands before he
gives out the community and and stuff
but you go into the I don't know if I'm
supposed to be telling maybe there's a
lot of secrets and stuff did you sign an
NDA you didn't [ __ ] kiddin but so you
go into the back and it was my job to
get the wine ready in all the water to
wash the Bruce sands and the communion
and the communion comes in a box and it
look like [ __ ] crackers they're like
basically jesus crackers subscribe so
you like you when you're eating it like
during the mass like you're eating the
body of Christ or whatever I was like I
remember just looking at this box being
like well I guess they never thought
about like how the church gets the
community cuz it's a box of crackers I
was just like legislate was below it was
like a Puritan yeah I know I just never
ever ever thought like how the churches
yeah communion where it comes from it's
just a true yeah so it's just like
opening this sleeve of like Ritz Jesus
crackers and putting it in this length
beautiful goblet and like you know
carrying it out my little tray just
maths or whatever but the worst I talk
about this in a video I did recently the
worst was like there's a special Mass it
was like Easter or something and you
know they don't really after you get the
feel of like being a mass that's like
that's what you do every week Pro added
you know that was young just like you 9
or 10 or something but one day was a
special Mass and everyone like the the
sisters nuns or whatever bows like I
stressed out like the priest has got
stressed out there are a lot of people
and you know think they got to give good
like little speech I'm sermon or
whatever we call it and they didn't
really give us much instruction
and one of the priests or something you
handed me this giant like chain with a
giant of lives like this big like you
know like a large grapefruit-sized fall
[ __ ] gets a massive lighter and just
like lights it and he goes all right
carry this today like when you do your
go in the thing and it's a giant ball of
incense and it is like so intense it is
[ __ ] like filling up my entire face
I'm walking and holding up nothing me
and I'm just getting dizzier and dizzier
and dizzier like on incense well because
I use the sort of faint sometimes as a
kid I don't really know why look I got
tested for like anemia and that sort of
thing I was always kind like it's just a
little bit like a fainting kid like we
used to just watch like cartoons and
[ __ ] that make you feel like dainty like
I would cast outta bed my blood draw
yeah yeah like you're just a fainty kid
and so I'm just like carrying it like
you starting to see that like grainy
black like you know you've got to [ __ ]
it this yeah and I like kept it together
and like thank God we like stopped or
like the procession part was like over
so someone like came and took it like
hung it up on the wall he just took a
giant breath I like a little robe like
oh my god you're such a high V little
kid baby I know and I totally you know
never in a million years cuz you're like
under a lot of stress during those
things like you don't want to mess it up
like a room full of adults like looking
back now I totally could have been like
hey can someone take this I'm not
feeling so good but I couldn't it was
like I was at work that's like adorable
but like heartbreaking at the same time
like I would've like other kids
confirmed is gonna [ __ ] eat it right
now but we're I did like some church
plays like I took that [ __ ] seriously
but uhm yeah that's what I did when I
was like that age that's an altar so
that's really cute is really cute sorry
Jesus crackers Jesus where did they come
from do they just get her from the Jesus
store I think so umm I mean if you guys
have any funny job experiences that you
want to share with us we'd love to read
them in the comments
because uh because all jobs are funny
well yeah
all jobs are funny were you ever a camp
counselor did you ever go to camp
um not sleep away you never went to
sleepaway camp no I don't think I did
really huh did you go to like day camps
like what did you do no I did a swap
yeah sports camps and I played I did
baseball camps I did sports camps like
all sports and then I did like after the
age of like 12 I would go to like
clinics Wow which is like college put
them on or whatever organization had the
resources would put those on but yeah
they were already sports oriented I
never did sleepaway camp I only just
like went camping with my family but
number one sleep way did you ever want
to go to sleepaway camp yeah I think I
did I just I don't know why I never did
maybe I did honestly maybe I did I'm
forgetting it because I feel like I
forget so much about my childhood but um
not like I don't I don't really remember
going to sleepaway camp I went to like a
ton of friends or business yeah yeah so
I went to one that I really didn't like
it was like the popular one like a
really popular camp my brother liked it
but I didn't like it at all because it
just felt like a long extended version
of middle school that ran through the
summer yeah
like it was clicky and like yeah yeah
then I went to an all-girls like
leadership camp and that place was the
bomb because we would just sit around
and like talk about our feelings all day
it's like it's like teenage girl heaven
yeah you know sounds fun you like to
just you go when you just like sullen
all day but like you're with other
sullen teenagers so then you get to feel
better so in half right yeah I was a
dramatic teenager yeah I think all
teenagers were dramatic teenagers but I
was a camp I like one of my favorite
jobs ever Tuesday was being a camp
counselor like watching the kids
so my fade you know I think I might have
done like a day camp counselor mmm but
never did sleepaway camp counseling I
never sleep away camp counseling I was
only a date yeah you know I think my day
camp counseling was the YMCA I think I
did or the boys and growth I can't
remember what
where was but it was one of those places
I went to the Boys and Girls Club - yeah
high five I loved the Boys and Girls
Club was the best I used to go and watch
all the basketball games at boys girls
club because it was just like my it was
so much fun like he watched don't want
in Santa Monica mmm yeah on Lincoln
that's awesome in there forever
how's it really what a location that
ones in Jersey I used to get a cup of
noodles and send the audience and watch
games for hours and I loved it really I
can't eat it now but when I was a kid I
was like cup noodles and basketballs do
it where I grew up the like the place to
go
like if you're a kid and hang out was
the YMCA or the JCC yeah ours was the
boys Girls Club the YMCA dude the YMCA
was gross but the JCC was the [ __ ]
bomb oh my god you didn't have to be
Jewish to [ __ ] go in here same with
the Boys and Girls Club to take a what's
Christian club right well YMCA the YMCA
is what the other I mistook that yes sir
yeah that's I know it's the same thing I
love that was the best no look the we
used to go at like after school you go
to the JCC and like hang out like the
Teen Center would ya or you like go
swimming you go to the [ __ ] and get
some snacks like there's just very
friendly kids like to have a place to go
after school yeah there's like causing
trouble and [ __ ] we also had
after-school programs are similar like
you know stay after school and there was
like games you could play and you know
count yeah
where was this for school - do you I
only did them after school so I don't
know but thinking about that as an adult
like what a drunk thing to do as an eye
teacher for club you tell me I have to
be here at 4:30 in the morning so
[ __ ] can play war ball and
dodgeball everyone be sleeping here yeah
there's this game I don't I don't
[ __ ] remember what it's called but it
was like this board and it was on like a
stand and it was like pool you had this
stick and there were these little pucks
that you hit around and you hit him and
there was like this map on the dude if I
see a picture of that that would be like
a nostalgia central if any of you know
what I'm talking about all boy know it's
like you know it's it's the size of like
maybe half a pool table yeah and it's
you know like a wood board and there's
like a map on it and then there's like
wood little planks that direct you know
different things and the goal is to like
do certain things or get your pucks in
certain areas to get more points but we
had those the obstacle program and we
would play that for hours on end like
hours I would go home on his dark I've
literally never heard of set I think it
might have been an either a West Coast
thing or a different time gap thing but
if an even though I'm talking about send
me a picture and I'll a nostalgia my
face off because I know exam I had like
what it looks like a prom to our picture
of it should try and find one so we can
play it oh my god I would love to have
one of those we should play like a lot
of man kala kala kala with it yeah the
mark not marbles their little jewels and
you drop him in the dude you know who
used to [ __ ] crush that game in G
Devon my brother used to [ __ ] cheat
so bad he's amazing in all games he's
amazing at cheating and then accusing
you of cheating oh my god when he didn't
I love watching him play games with your
mom
like that's the funniest thing he will
my mom cheats do cuz he that's the thing
like she'll cheat like even if it's on
accident she'll do something that cause
please okay I'm gonna give her the
badges oh you can you see my mom she she
she just like exams number than I have
been just then Devon just like has none
of it yeah it's ridiculous oh boy I'm
just so like I can't cheat a feel too
bad I can never I felt that was pretty
calling people lesson I know I felt
terrible but like most of them think got
it you know laughing by the end of it we
edited a lot someone created a YouTube
account called Adam from lumber and
commented on that video yeah
Adam Adam for Mom berry so good ah but
like I said guys hit us up in the
comments with your funny job sores
because we'd love to read them yeah I
want to read them funny for sure and
yeah good good little reminiscing of our
jobs thanks to Squarespace again for
funk sponsoring our podcast Thank You
sighs always Squarespace we love you
like I said this last time Squarespace
sponsored us tweet us your Squarespace
websites if you have them because I love
checking them out
Squarespace is very popular so I've seen
a lot of people who they already had
websites for Squarespace or beast got
them from our podcast but those websites
and send us your before and after
pictures yeah of witness your personal
blog and then you're on your scares
better Squarespace with yeah ah
beautiful templates easy design
customers for 24/7
Squarespace comment or JJ check out 10%
off your website Thank You Squarespace
thank you spare space and thank you this
shirt yeah
sure it's comfortable so is this shirt
this is hook grip not Squarespace look
quick for the man yes okay um but thanks
guys for watching and listening and
hanging out we'll see you guys next week
for another JJ podcast yeah good podcast
pop up later guys
okay bye friends ealier whoa whoa do I
get hifiberry you're just gonna ignore
me oh how much do I have to have fun
you